and here's the replay he's run he runs
right by her she clearly yells something
he turns around he points at her he
tells security you've got to get this
little girl out of here 13 year old girl
calling the indigenous player an ape so
afterwards this girl actually called to
apologize and they called adam goods to
apologize and the interesting thing is
that well number one adam goods kind of
understands what what's going on here
right he says to come to the boundary
line and hear a 13 year old girl call me
an ape and it's not the first time on a
footy field that i've been referred to
as a monkey or an ape it was shattering
however he said unfortunately it's what
she hears in the environment she's grown
up in that has made her think it's okay
to call people names it's not her fault
she's 13 she's still so innocent i don't
put any blame on her
um
a 13 year old can if a 13 year old
thinks it's okay to yell racist stuff at
a australian rules football game are
they at all to blame or at that age is
it clearly the result of their
environment